تختلف الاحصائيات وتتذبذب الارقام لكن
المشترك هو النمو المتوالي الذي شهده
الاقتصاد السعودي في عام 20 22 حيث اعلن
في الهيئه العامه للاحصاء تسجيل النمو في
الناتج المحليه الاجمالي بما يقارب تسعه
في المئه في الربع الثالث من العام الجاري
مقارنه بالربع الثالث من العام الماضي هذا
ارتفاع جاء مدعوما بارتفاع الانشطه
النفسيه في اكثر من 14% اضافه الى الانشطه
غير النفطيه التي سجلت نموا رباعيا بسته
في المئه واخيرا ارتفاع الانشطه الحكوميه
بنسبه النمو
مشاهدينا فيما يخص الناتج المحليه
الاجمالي تحديدا فقد تجاوز الفا من زياره
ريال بالاسعار الجاريه في الربع الثالث من
العام
كافه الانشطه الاقتصاديه التي سجلت نموا
على اساسا سنويا جاء في مقدمتها نشاط
الزيت والغاز بنسبه اقت من 15% ثم صناعات
التحويليه باحد 10% وفي المرتبه الثالثه
انشطه النقل والتخزين بينما جاءت او جاء
العقار في المرتبات الاقل بين الانشطه
الاقتصاديه
الانشطه غير النفطيه في السعوديه مشاهدينا
لاعبه دورا رئيسيا في تنويع مصادر نمو
الاقتصاد بوثيره تعد اسرع منذ 12 سنه هذا
واوضح الاحصاء السعوديه ايضا ان الوالدات
ارتفعت بمعدل بلغ نحو واحد وثلاثين في
المئه في 20 22 ونحو 20% من النمو حققته
تجاره الصادره السعوديه خلال الفتره ذاتها
وانضم الينا هنا في الاستديو الكاتب
والبحث الاقتصاديه الدكتور علي الحازمي
الدكتور الرابع من الرياض حياك الله
الاقتصاد السعوديينما بشكل يعني مبترد
خلال هذا العام كل ربع يرتفع اكثر فاكثر
حتى وصلنا الى الربع الثالث
8.8 عندما نقارنه ب 2021 لماذا هنا اعتقد
الارتفاعات هي صناعه في هذا العام ولكن
اذا تتبع لها تاريخيا منذ الربع الثاني من
العام 20 21 تقريبا نحن في الربع السادس
من الارتفاعات همم انا اعتقد هو يتوافق مع
التوقعات المملكه يتوافق مع
الخطه الاستراتيجيه والتحولات
الاستراتيجيه التي تعيشها المملكه ما يحدث
حقيقه الانشطه النفطيه ربما لعبت دور بشكل
كبير ارتفاع اسعار النفط نعم لعب دور كبير
وده همم شاهدنا هذا الربع فقط تقريبا
الانشطه النفطيه زائدا همم نتحدث عن
الانفاق او الانشطه الحكوميه شكلت تقريبا
5% من
اجمالي الناتجه المحلي الذي يصل يتجاوز
التريليون ريال همم انا انا اعتقد بان
التحولات الهيكليه التي او التغييرات
الهيكليه في الاقتصاد السعودي لعبت دور
محوري ومهم في هذه في هذه الارقام منذ
بدايه العام 20 22
وصناع القرار في المملكه يتحدثون عن هذا
النمو كان هناك مد وجذب في المنظمات
الدوليه بداوا تقريبا من 4.5% كانوا
اقتصادي اليوم خلصنا الى هذا الربع الى
8.8% في المجمل ما سيكون عليها هذا العام
يصل الى مستويات الثمانيه فاصله 5% كما
اوضح معالي الوزير الجدعان هذا همم بنهايه
العام تتحدث انه حيوصل للمجموع كاملا
ثمانيه فاصله همم 5% وهذا بالنسبه
للسعوديه عندما نتحدى التاريخيه منذ
تقريبا ثلاثه عشر عاما لم تتحقق هذه
الارقام همم ايش ممكن نتوقع للناتج المحلي
قيمه الناتج المحلي كم ستصبح في نهايه هذا
العاميه فعليا يتجاوز الترلي والريال
ترليون دولار نعم حقيقه هذه هو
الفيصل في هذه السنه كنا نتحدث في بدايه
السنه بان هذه السنه ستكون الناتج المحلي
تريليوني شككت بعض المنظمات الدوليه اتت
الارقام حقيقه مؤكدا انا اعتقد سنصل الى
مستويات الثلاثه فاصله تسعه تريليون وهذا
رقم كبير ويتوافق حقيقه مع مات التوجهات
من رؤيه المملكه 2030 متى سنصل 3.9 اه
رجال يعني سنصل الان في هذا العام ثلاثه
فاصل تسعه وبيعام 20 23 ستكون ثلاثه فاصله
تقريبا سته وثلاثه فاصله همم ثمانيه في
حلول عام حتى ما اتوقعت انه العمل القادم
لن يكون يعني عاما همم اقتصادي همم
دعنا نقول باسما سيكون هناك بالحديث عن
الركود اقتصادي لحديث عن الكساد الحديث عن
يعني الربع الاول والربع ثاني ستكون سنوات
اقتصاديه همم مصاحبه ليس على يعني بعد كده
على لسان كثير من المحللين الخبراء
الاقتصاديين ايضا كذلك هذه كيف ممكن تاثر
على هذا النمو السريع تحدث عن همم تقريبا
الربع السادس كما ذكرت وامامنا من الربع
السابع وثامن لكن سيحدث انا اعتقد العام
نعم حاله عدم اليقين التي تهيمين على
المشهد الاقتصادي هي ليست والده اللحظه
منذ بدايه العام 20 22 وكان حقيقه منظمات
الدوليه تتحدث بان الاقتصاد العالمي لايسر
بشكل جيد كانت هناك توقعات لنمو الاقتصاد
العالم وبعد ذلك خفضت المنظمات العالميه
هذه الارقام نعم حاله عدم اليقين تسيطر
على المشهد حاله الاغلاقات الصين محرك مهم
واستراتيجي لنمو العالمي كان هناك منطلق
زيرو كورونا او زيرو كوفيد اغلاقات الان
نوعا ما هناك انفراجات نتحدث الاوضاع
الاوروبيه نعم كيف تنعكس علينا احنا يعني
احنا ما نبي نتحدث عن اللي صاير في همم
بصينا واللي في اوروبا احنا اكيد جزء طبعا
عملنا
بالنسبه همم بالنسبه لنا كيف ممكن يؤثر
على الناتج المحلي على الاقتصاد ايضا
السعودي على ديموميه الحركه على جذب
الاستثمار وغيرها طبعا اذا تحدثت عن
الناتج المحليه ان احنا نتحدث عن الانشطه
او ان اسعار النفط وهي محرك اساسي في
الناتج المحلي عندما نقول حاله عدم اليقين
هذا يعني بانه انخفاض الطلب على اسعار
النفط او اا مستقبلا وهذه من شانها ان
تؤثر على الناتج المحلي الاجمالي ولكن
اعتقد بان المراجعات الدوليه همم الدوريه
المنظمات واستشراف المستقبل من حيث زياده
الانتاج وحفظ الانتاج المملكه حقيقه نعم
تم تخفيض اثنين مليون برميل من الانتاج
ولكن هناك مراجعات دولي همم دوري الان
نتحدث عن اسعار النفطه في مستويات
الثمانين دولار وهي ارقام جيده ولكن اعتقد
بان الان نعم حاله عدم اليقين في المشهد
العالمي تؤثر على قرارات
من زياده وانخفاض وعندما كان الاجتماع في
اربعه من ديسمبر تحدث همم سمو الامير عبد
العزيز بن سلمان بقى قال بان سنستمر في
المرحله الرابعه والمراجعات كما هي لذلك
هذا هو يؤثر حقيقه الدول النفطيه يؤثر
عليها مثل هذه المراجعات بشكل كبير وزياده
الانتاج او خفض الانتاج النفطي ممتاز احنا
نتحدث عن افضل اداء فصلي في 13 عاما
والحديث عن التحولات الاقتصاديه في
السعوديه الحديث كذلك عن الاصلاحات ايضا
همم الحديث ايضا حتى عن اليوم ميزانيه همم
سعوديه همم قويه في الميزانيه كذلك كان
متوقعا او اكثر من ما كان متوقعا فبالتالي
اتحدث عن الاداء الفصل نهايه العام هل
سيكون اكثر مما تن- نتوقع ام لا التوقعات
ربما ستكون اقرب الى ان ثمانيه فاصله خمسه
مثل هذا الكلام يعني
على نهايه العام لم يتبقى تقريبا الا 15
يوم اعلنت حقيقه الميزانيه لهذا العام
بارقام حقيقيه كانت الارادات النفطيه وصلت
الى مستويات 812 مليار ايرادات غير نفطيه
كانت مست 300 تقريبا و52 مليار في المجمل
انا اعتقد بان هذا العام قد انتهينا وخرجت
ارقام اؤكد لك بانها بنسبه 99% حقيقيه
الرهان هو على العام القادم حتى على مستوى
الفوائد همم هذه العام تتحدثين عن فائض
102 مليار السنه القادمه بحقيقه هناك تحفظ
نوعا ما بسبب الاوضاع العالميه نتحدث عن
فائض ربما يصل فقط الى مستويات ال16 مليار
ريال لذلك انا اعتقد حتى عندما عملت
ميزانيه العامه 2023 كان هناك نظرا لاوضاع
العالميه ونعم هي نظره ربما لا تكون
تفاؤليه بشكل كبير ولكن على الاقل نحن
داخل المناطق الايجابيه او البوستاتف في
النمو الاقتصادي على المجمل التي تتحدثين
على اقوى 20 اقتصاد في العالم هناك فرق
كبير ما بين المملكه وما بين الدوله التي
لها لذلك احنا انا اعتقد في العالم
القادمه يتحدث عن ثلاثه فاصله سته في
المئه في النمو كم همم في المجمل انا
اعتقد من وجهه نظري هو ارقام اخذ نوعا ما
ربما نحقق ارقام افضل من هذا مستقبل على
كل هذه التفاصيل كل هذه المعلومات مع
تمنياتنا طبعا بنكون العام القادم هو عامل
اقتصادي جيد باسم يخالف كل التوقعات ان
شاء الله شكرا جزيلا لك الدكتور علي
الحازمي الباحث والكاتب الاقتصادي